on pourrait pas
[Musique]
maya est de retour cette petite abeille
et sicofi quand je l'invite elle et son
amie à participer à notre compétition
[Musique]
si vous perdez alors je ferai un exemple
pour les autres et prendrait la totalité
de votre miel d'été
les chercheuses ou quoi alors que les
jeux commencent
bonne chance partout on peut pas laisser
la maîtrise prendre notre miel bien
devant lumière qu'elle fait l'équipe tu
as maya sahli les 14 sont nuls point
final jennifer et mayor loup et violette
je crois qu'on va bien rigoler
on peut y arriver tous les insectes ont
un talent caché
la soirée bandas
pas tous non
maya l'abeille 2 les jeux de lumière
j'étais moi de tirs ont lieu le 18
juillet au cinéma